[Musique]
nous sommes encore dans une période
d'incertitude
on vient de voir les images d'olivier
vers en indiquant les chiffres de la
pandémie on ne peut pas dire que les
choses soient stabilisés c'est une
petite bombe lâchée par le new york
times l'europe a exporté 34 millions de
doses produites sur son territoire 9
millions chez nos grands amis anglais
qui ne sont pas très partageur de leur
côté quatre millions au canada 3
millions au mexique et environ un
million aux états unis elles vont
laisser le fait le mec le probant
plaintive accéder aux 8es mc12 l'aller
25 millions de doses dont on a besoin
nous européens pourquoi est ce qu'on les
ex forte alors que de leur côté les
états unis la grande bretagne et que ça
pourtant des rivaux très pudique et
c'est quoi c'est de la folie pas du tout
mais pas du tout on surveille on observe
si la situation devait évoluer
évidemment nous prendrions des décisions
mais à ce stade il n'y a pas lieu de
suspendre la vaccination dans ce
quinquennat la marque de l'échec des
mâles macron ce sera l'état régalien ce
sera l'insécurité on assiste impuissant
si j'ose dire en tout cas l'exécutif
l'est à la chronique quotidienne d'une
barbarie ordinaire sur la préfecture de
police et la zone de la préfecture de
police de paris où l'essentiel des
bornes ce qu'on sente si regardez depuis
2007 vous avez une baisse constante des
faits rattaché au bond par contre il ya
des phénomènes de violence et une
aggravation de la violence
jean christophe lagarde en garde à vue
pour détention d'armes vous n'en savait
pas plus que moi j'imagine je n'en sais
strictement rien et donc je préfère ne
rien dire et à la police a dû intervenir
à son domicile de danser après un appel
de ses proches expliquant qu'il aurait
menacé de se suicider et qu'il était
armé sur place les policiers ont
découvert des armes à feu certaines
étaient détenues légalement dans le
cadre de la pratique du tir sportif et
d'autres mondes
il a dit qu'il n'avait trait pas marine
le pen sa marine le pen ratio ne pas
l'inviter etienne il a raison il a
raison faut éviter ça s'appelle comment
son truc which the pas recevoir les gens
qui pour moi je joue pas le rôle
républicain je suis à la maison je veux
pas que certains tentent un de ces élus
qui incarne au palais les valeurs dans
lesquelles je crois bien croiser mes
enfants et mon épouse
voilà donc ce je le dis plus assume
totalement hollande arrive sur l'estrade
et dit bonjour à darmanin et là on sent
bon jour au beau bonjour le groupe
réaction de nicolas sarkozy on va revoir
sa tête la tête que fait nicolas sarkozy
la morale le surmoi comme dit fraude
c'est le résultat de l'intériorisation
des interdits parentaux ça veut dire que
s'il n'y a pas d'interdît à intérioriser
y aura pas de surmoi n'y aura pas de
morale donc revalorisé l'autoritaire 'le
valoriser les interdits et donc aussi
revaloriser les sanctions dont la sphère
gérard louvin la chaîne a diffusé deux
témoignages qui accuse le couple louvain
moines de viol puis une heure plus tard
une interview des deux avocats venus
répondre et défendre en plateau leurs
clients
l' affaire avait été révélée par le
journal le monde le 25 janvier dans ce
papier la vie brisée du neveu du
producteur de gérard louvin
ça a commencé par des 1/4 s pour
m'endormir je parle de daniel moyne et
puis et puis très vite très vite
on est passé à la main qu'on dirige sur
le sexe et le visage tournament sur le
sexe
d'après ce qu'on nous dit vos clients
auraient proposé une autre somme par
plus basse selon c'est un mensonge 250
sépare mensonges et j'ai une culture
mais mahut a encaissé
si gérard louvin et daniel moign avait
été coupable croyez pas qu'ils auraient
tout tolérer cette somme serait
grotesque
en fait de vous sentez salle quoi vous
vous sentez humilié vous sentez vous
vous sentez barriac quoi